meanwhile in Washington the house could
vote as early as today on a Democratic
resolution denouncing president Trump's
racist tweets moments ago the president
tweeted about those comments he wrote
those tweets are not racist I don't have
a racist bone in my body yesterday at
the White House he defended his
controversial comments calling for for
Democratic congresswoman all women of
color to go back to their home countries
all four are American citizens as far as
I'm concerned if you hate our country if
you're not happy here you can leave and
that's what I say all the time that's
what I said in a tweet which I guess
some people think is controversial a lot
of people love it the congresswoman
responded yesterday at a news conference
calling for the president's impeachment
Nancy Cordes was there and joins us from
Capitol Hill Nancy what are Republicans
saying well Anthony the top Republican
in the house Kevin McCarthy is defending
the president he says mr. Trump isn't
racist he's just frustrated about these
for Congress women and their political
views no matter what the president says
this country belongs to you and it
belongs to everyone the four female
lawmakers who have come to be nicknamed
the squad forcefully condemned the
president this is the agenda of white
nationalists and said his comments were
part of a pattern he is if nothing else
predictable
simply a continuation of his racist and
xenophobic playbook a Republican
backlash gained steam too but the tweets
are a racist and xenophobic period in
the story it's dangerous it's demeaning
to our fellow Americans and that's
simply wrong others defended him come on
of course the president's not racist the
comments that they have made the squad
all of them have been so anti-american
so far 11 GOP lawmakers have condemned
the president's tweets outright 18 have
criticized both Democrats and mr. Trump
10 are supporting him leaving more than
200 Republicans who have stayed silent
the new democratic resolution will force
them to go on the record and vote the
measure quote strongly condemns
president donald trump's racist comments
that have legitimized and increased fear
and hatred of new Americans and people
of color I hear the way she talks about
Al Qaeda the president insisted it's the
women who have used hateful speech can
you respond to some of the president's
specific claims most notably that you're
a communist and that you're Pro al Qaeda
it's beyond time to ask Muslims to
condemn terrorists we are no longer
going to allow the digna fication of
such ridiculous ridiculous statement the
president referenced a 2013 video in
which Omar talked about Al Qaeda but she
did not praise the group jurika as he
claimed all right Nancy Cordes thank you
very much